the Calabar burrowing python might be
the toughest snake on earth it has
incredibly thick skin that is very
resistant to punctures these snakes have
an odd shape their heads and tails look
very similar this is thought to be a
tactic to fool predators when threatened
the Calabar hides its head and offers
its tail Calabar snakes grow to about 1
metre in length when compared with 13
other snakes of about the same size
Calabar snakes had skin that was 15
times as thick on top of this numerical
superiority the deep dermis is composed
of neatly arranged collagen bundles more
like the tough dermis of a white rhino
than its thin skin 2 snake brethren the
hinges between the Calabar scales and
its body are also specialized hinges are
thought to be useful for flexibility but
could be considered a weak spot in a
snake's armor the Calla bars hinges are
much smaller than other species all this
adds up to these snakes being very
resistant to punctures when tested with
hypodermic needles and a force
transducer its skin was orders of
magnitude harder to pierce than any
other snake tested why might a snake
need such a tough hide after all other
snakes that have shared behaviors like
slithering through leaf litter and tails
that look like their heads don't have
such a durable dermis but the Calabar
has a hunting habit that might be the
answer the team thinks the snake's armor
evolved to ward off bites from the
mothers of the baby burrowing rodents it
preys upon even with all these anti
puncture adaptations the snake's skin
remains flexible a combination that
already has piqued the interest of a
pharmaceutical company seeking to make
tougher medical gloves that don't
restrict movement
you
you
you